welcome back to cbs this morning the u.s
plans to start withdrawing thousands of
troops from kabul this week many afghans
are still as you see crowding the
airport they're trying to get out while
the taliban leaders say they will
prevent more from leaving some veterans
are trying to help those behind taliban
roadblocks to escape the country we
spoke with three veterans who served in
afghanistan and a u.s contractor whose
family fled the country back in the
1990s and eventually settled here in
america they told us what it's been like
watching the taliban take control
i was a west point graduate and in 2012
i served as a cultural support team
leader in afghanistan i was in the air
force for 20 years i deployed to
afghanistan four times i am a retired
marine i served in afghanistan as part
of task force leatherneck my name is
safi rauf and i was a civilian
contractor in afghanistan for four years
my family immigrated from
afghanistan to a refugee camp in
pakistan i didn't fit into either side i
was kind of in the middle and looked at
a lot of those people they looked like
me a lot of them looked at me like i was
there to hunt them in 2000
2001 i lost
a couple of very close friends
and then to go there and see
how we hadn't
been able to
to improve the situation much
we were able to work with
girls who went to school we were able to
work with midwives in a clinic everybody
made it home but
you know
teams that we worked with not everybody
made it home those are hard hard losses
our military mission afghanistan will
conclude on august 31st i always knew
that the united states was going to
leave afghanistan i think i was
apprehensive about how it was all going
to unfold i was happy i was happy that
this was a
hopefully an end to an
era initially it was a depression it was
an anger it was a frustration it was
wondering why did
we all sacrifice so many things to just
watch it all go away again
a lot of anger
not sadness but a lot of anger
towards
how hastily we left but also a lot of
the times towards the afghan government
they did not give their soldiers a
fighting chance
shock
numb sad uh angry
and that's the place i land on
when i think about
friends and family
that that should be here when i think
about one of my closest friends that
would have retired around the same time
as myself i worried about the girls that
went to school
would they still be able to go
i vacillate between feeling hopeless and
feeling like there's there is something
that i can do to try to advocate on
behalf of these afghans and our allies
those interpreters that worked with us
that bled with us and making sure that
the promise we made them they are not
left behind and we bring them they
belong there this is their home we
worked with a lot of locals on base so
you would think about what is he going
home to what's his life like and now
just for having served me breakfast is
he going to die
so i worry about that i definitely do
we've already
endured so much with post-traumatic
stress and combat stress and this is
just a trigger i'm very concerned
we could see
more
suicides than we normally would
people that aren't able to see the other
side are only going to see the negative
and and the loss of territory and the
loss of the current goal instead of
being able to see the good that was done
[Music]
i hope the little girls that i
interacted with in afghanistan
you know they
remember
the freedom i hope that we have given
them hope we saw somebody who was
born he's 20 years old now
for two decades he has learned how to
read he's learned how to write
and communicate with the rest of the
world
so i don't think taliban can contain
that for too long our efforts there for
20 years gave the people a chance it
gave them hope it gave almost an entire
generation of people a life
that they could have never had before we
did not waste our time we did not
sacrifice for nothing
boy that's a that's a very important
point because i think a lot of people
wonder as we leave what what where's the
point
you know it's tough and every time you
look at it you sort of hold your breath
because you feel it could go so wrong so
quickly that we're still not out of
danger there yet it's very very
frightening yeah but 20 years is a
generation and that's a generation of
girls it's a generation of society
building those people do move on and
they could do something mighty in the
world